- So, what am I pronouncing, Indian names?
(laughs) I know nothing about that.
- Do-ree-tee?
- How the heck am I
supposed to pronounce D-H-R?
- Dorito, do-ree-tee?
- (rolls R on tongue)
It's like a little motor.
Dhriti, that's how you say it?
- Sounds like if I was a rapper,
that'd be like my car that I'm drivin' in.
- A hot ass Dhriti.
- (laughs) Vuh-jay?
- Vee-jay?
- Uh, vee-jay?
- Like an MTV VJ?
- Vice-nah-vee?
- Vish-nah-vee?
- Come on now.
- Va-hash-uh-nee-vah.
- Vaishnavi?
- See, I'm so close at all
of these, I'm so close.
- It looks like it's
pronounced as Anushka,
but I bet you it's way off.
- Anushka.
- Oh, yeah.
- I think I got that one.
- Like a Vivian, like an Indian Vivian.
- Viv-eck?
- Vivek, I know, 'cause
Vivek Shraya, the musician.
- Vivek, oh, it's a guy's name. (laughs)
- Now, normally, it's
like too many letters,
I'm not using them all,
but I feel like this one
could use a couple extra letters.
- See, I wanna say it's Aayush,
but I kinda think it's An-oosh.
- Aayush?
- Ai-you-shhh.
- Too many A's, like Aaron.
- Oh my god, what?
- Choke, choke, Chokalingam?
- Choke-uh-ling-gahm.
- (laughs) That sounds dirty.
- The way that I said it,
it sounded like a disease.
- My-tea-lee?
- Mutt-til-ee?
- Okay, this one looks good.
- We don't need that A there.
- Mah, mah-eet-tuh-lee.
Wait.
- Got it.
- Carrie.
- Kah-ree?
- Is it pronounced Car-eh, or just Car?
- That's very sexy, Care-eh.
- That sounds confident, right,
it's all about confidence
in how you pronounce the
name, even if it's dead wrong.
- I think the names are very beautiful.
- Pronunciation of names
is really important,
so even if it's super
hard, just try your hardest
and don't automatically
go for the nickname
because that's someone's
name, it's important.